say hello down at the end of the couch
Michael nolza host of the Michael Noel's
show he's out in LA most times but he
joins us live today
Michael's star among the stars yeah so
Michael what do you make of the
president sent out a tweet yesterday law
enforcement look into looking into some
corruption down south here's the exact
tweet law enforcement is looking into
another big corruption scandal having to
do with election fraud in Broward and
Palm Beach counties Florida Florida
voted for Rick Scott mysteriously down
in Broward County apparently more VAT of
more ballots more votes are just popping
up that's right they found a box of
provisional ballots in a closet
somewhere a teacher found it I think the
word provisional means it's the
provision in case the Republican wins
then they go in there they find the
provision which is to give a bunch more
Democrat votes can we find one Democrat
in this country who's willing to concede
a race I think Al Gore is still in
Florida digging through those boats
Hillary Clinton is really the president
Andrew Gilliam now is unconceived this
is the moral hazard of turning election
day into election season now we have
early voting I think three years out you
can go provisional ballots mail-in
ballots this is the moral hazard because
it creates the opportunity for all of
these shenanigans and we become a
laughingstock well you know when when
Marco Rubio weighs in when I saw his
tweets and we talked to him last night
he is not a firebrand he is not a flame
thrower he's a guy to sit back it has to
be pushed forward to do this he is
outraged about what is taking place the
lead is cut in half since election
that's right I don't know where I said
pretty soon we're gonna end up with a
count that's larger than the population
of Florida this always seems to happen
and there is a ton of corruption
specifically in Broward County we've
known this for years and years and years
and it's unfortunate because we're the
greatest republic in the world and we
should be able to conduct our own
elections and we should punish the
people who are corrupting that process
that's why Rick Scott has issued this
lawsuit to try and figure out what's
going on in the president as we saw
wants other law enforcement agents
including federal law enforcement to
investigate it but you mentioned
Democrats not be able to concede races
we've seen that since 2016 many of the
Democrats who backed Hillary Clinton
also backed Democratic candidates in the
midterm elections talk about Hollywood's
fact or non effect on these elections
you can't out celebrity Donald Trump
it's just not possible you cannot do it
he's the biggest politician and to the
top entertainer in the world and this
takes away all of that Democrat star
power they used to put their rock stars
up against our milk toast candidates
President Trump is not milk toast and I
think that now because politics is
entertainment because it's the social
media age Trump is engaging with his
base all the time
I think he's the greatest civics teacher
in American history I think he is
keeping that base engaged and that is
why the Blue Wave couldn't happen the
blue wave demanded high democrat
enthusiasm and very low Republican
enthusiasm but people are constantly
consuming the news constantly consuming
politics and you had historically high
off year republican turnout and it turns
that blue wave into a purple puddle what
Michael what did you make of the fact
that after the Tuesday night election
and the Democrats won the house I mean
they were going to win the house and
they wanted and they should have been
celebrating and they did and then on the
Republican side they said okay we lost
the house go back two years ago to 2016
after the Democrats did not win the
presidency there was there were a lot of
day after you know Wednesday morning
quarterbacks go and what did we do wrong
there were protests all sorts of stuff
of course you know they've really got to
cut it out with all of this mob violence
we saw this pecan ant Aoife in the
streets they went after Tucker Carlson
they refused to give up elections this
is really hurting them Democrats would
have done much better you might have
seen a blue wave if they would just
behave like gentlemen and ladies and in
a civilized way and not encourage all
this mob violence at the top of people's
the minds in this election was that
Cavanaugh effect these mobs coming out
against people and it's bad news because
it knocked out a number of 20/20
Democrat contenders and so now there's
this hill TV poll that says the number
one concern of the above none of the
above beats Hillary Biden everybody else
know that after the election after
Republicans lost the house the only
people still riding and protesting or
Democrats on the left even though they
won the house that's it's never enough
it's never enough because they make such
an idol out of politics they don't seem
to understand a balance about anything
in the world now there
after talking heads now they're going
after commentators and passions that's
exactly right
wonders abound right who might end up
running for the Senate seat in Alabama
Michael knows thanks so much right to
see you